I remember watching this in the movies
and like people went ape everybody would
be terrified of shooting that cape on
set the render engine is very
photorealistic but all of the texture
work is stylized
okay hold up though how did they film
that yeah yeah this is awesome
hey how's it going welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react we are joined by two
special guests today we got Joe Farrell
on the couch and Clint you remember him
Joe Farrell is a master of VFX
supervision he worked on movies such as
Xiang Chi he did Wolf of Wall Street
Transformers I wrote about a couple of
movies among other movies we're just
excited to have you back man thanks man
I really enjoy hanging out with you guys
I think I remember the last time I
mentioned it's very therapeutic for me
to come here so let's keep going with
this this session is free
okay Moon Knight is a brand new show out
on Disney plus it's based in the Marvel
Universe there's some really cool stuff
going on here there's a lot of really
awesome double reflection VFX going on I
think the suit is entirely VFX I believe
so most wait really
foreign
[Music]
that's a real guy wearing a real suit
there wouldn't be any reason that would
cost more money to make it digital than
it would be to have a real suit now they
might be doing his head it's definitely
not a stunt guy he told me he's not full
CG right there that was definitely full
CG right there and then that's real and
then that's real yeah you can see it in
the sub texture on his shoulder yeah
yeah so for me what I'm seeing is all of
the high detail in the cloth itself
there's a little bit of wrinkling going
on but there's also like this bump
texture that when it cuts to the wide CG
shot here maybe it's there and I'm just
not seeing it but it just kind of seems
a little too smooth so it's an
interesting uh example because that is
definitely a real person wearing it
although they're probably wearing some
degree of head but what it would do is
be cutting out the eyes you could do it
without but you'd want to be able to
sort of track the head afterwards
because it's one thing to just sort of
say all right we'll do it all in post
but it's another thing to then spend
weeks and weeks and weeks re-tracking
the head and fixing it you're losing
time and money at that point to do that
clearly the eyes obviously that's
digital and you can see the glow of the
eyes so it's definitely digital from the
neck up but I think you'll find they
have been wearing something that's white
that's representing all the way around
it look at the way the light on the bus
reacts with his head it looks it's got a
little bit of a wrap it looks perfect to
me it's also the eyes are moving and
manipulating and getting a performance
and there's a very good chance you would
put that a real practical thing on and
be like and people like I can't hear him
is a hell of a punch back there okay
hold up though how did they film that
we're looking at the reflection of a
person and the real person and that's
not too hard to do it's just simply like
rotoscope at his hand and head and
whatnot and do the same performance
twice you marry them together but the
camera is moving back and forth and now
you're having to replicate the exact
same camera move for both performances
and you can do that with like a motion
control rig you couldn't bring a motion
control rig on for one shot you could
maybe bring it on for a huge stunt
sequence and plan ahead but this one
here there's too much of this that would
have been coming up and how they're
doing it is they're just shooting him on
the right they're shooting him on the
right for a performance and the bus is
just as is on the inside or they got up
so the bus is just as is they've rotored
around his hand yeah and then what they
do is they now go and shoot the inverse
that happens on the reflections and now
they need to calculate where the camera
is and they need to then invert that and
they may have simply have shot that
performance on the left hand side they
could have done it the same day the
human body is a lot of there's like a 15
like flexibility in the perspective of
what a human body can get away with and
that amount of Parallax that's happening
in there is not enough for that to be
thrown off so maybe they're doing a
little bit of movement they've got a
little bit of a float happening on the
inverse camera he's probably shot on a a
solid black duveteen he wouldn't be on a
blue screen it'd be my guess because why
bother you know you could just Spotlight
him down and so that no it's a
completely separate shot the reason
being is I'm not sure about the focus if
you start at the very beginning of the
shot their heads are right where Oscar's
reflection is and I don't believe
they're Crystal sharp you can watch him
pull out of focus there when he turns
they rack out and so on and I'm sure
that you know the the VFX super is
paying close attention but this could be
an example of sort of well the story
needs to be told and you need to be able
to see his performance and this is just
the way it is and so sometimes you know
we'll push VFX just to tell the story
enough that we might lean him in a
little bit sharper than you would
normally have done to have told the
story out has 100 photo real where would
the reflections position be in the focus
plane of things I'm very confused as to
where that would be it would be as if
it's that far away on the other side
it's the distance that the the subject
is from the glass I see I see the real
actors a foot away from the reflection
yes you need to focus a foot beyond the
glass so basically your focus moves
through that yeah and it will put him in
Focus but he in the foreground would go
out of course yeah I think there's also
a very underappreciated element here and
that's the fact that they're removing
the real reflection of Oscar Isaac's
performance on the right here's probably
what they're doing for that because
there's a good chance that the camera
and the rig and all that sort of stuff
would appear in the shock my guess is
that there's no glass there at all I was
going to say yeah slapping his hand on
something that's probably down in the
bottom left corner and then they're just
removing that out of the frame and then
you'll put putting the real reflection
in there what about the bus people well
they're real there's no glass there so
they're really in there and that's a
real insight the reflection of the
building you're seeing and the real
reflection is All Digital yeah we had to
do that a lot on shangshi where you've
got Reflections so basically the rule of
thumb was when you're inside the object
that's got glass you keep those
Reflections and when you're outside
looking in you remove the glass and you
you keep those and you put the
reflections outside are fake that was
the best way of doing it as far as
figuring it out so here they're outside
so they can replicate what we're not
seeing behind us so that's digital Oscar
Isaac's reflection performance is
digital wait did he just start
transforming yeah yeah so so on top of
all that right you got mummy mode
in choreography the timing up of this
performance I don't envy the task of
having to do that like a costume coming
out of nowhere always hard work
[Music]
it's definitely a dude really in there
definitely running around punching
people and he's probably wearing some
form of that costume yeah he's wearing a
white costume because you need it to be
white it'd also need to be the same
girth yeah muscle build so they don't so
they don't grab through well through and
so they come in contact properly and
also so when you when you've got a dark
suit coming up to a white suit you'd
want the same bounce because that suit
would be throwing off light a camera guy
couldn't film this without having
somebody really there really doing all
the performance
everybody would be terrified of shooting
that cape on set it didn't move like a
normal Cape but it's a magic Cape magic
capes go a long way well the main thing
there is that like it's spinning very
quickly but not going outwards you know
you have the classic shot of the dancers
spinning and their dress goes outwards
into like a little like disc blade but
his doesn't it just kind of goes and I
think that's creatively motivated by
what's happening versus like oh that's
not physics level real I'd really want
to see the the outtakes of a real Cape
when they did 37 takes and the cape's
like caught around him
there's a scene from Attack of the
Clones that I wanted to take another
look at
[Music]
I remember watching this in the movies
and like people went ape D I had never
been so hyped
so of course uh there's a bunch going on
here but what I really wanted to talk
about was the intricacies of Yoda's
animation there's a lot in this movie
that is dated that's understandable but
I specifically want to get your
impression of Yoda's animation and his
clothing
I had the benefit of the beginning of my
career I actually learned how to do
old-fashioned Optics so like the
original Star Wars were done where they
would bend light through lenses and then
they would combine different elements
it's all about lenses it's all about the
imperfections of lenses and all that
sort of stuff and then comes along these
Star Wars movies and they basically go
all in on digital and so what happens is
you end up with an image that's like
perfect from the top left to the bottom
right corner all the way through it and
as a consequence something that's
perfect like that really shocks you when
you first see it Frank Oz would animate
Yoder and the way he could move the Yoda
we got used to it it's like it became in
our genetic code to watch something and
so he can move the puppet in in strange
ways and when he moves it they mentioned
the you know the the new ones when they
did Yoder they made sure the ears were
like jiggling around just like they did
when the puppets did it because the the
digital one they didn't do do it because
they were animating him because they
thought well his ears that was a fake
puppet if this was a real character it
wouldn't have the little ears doing that
on the end they put it back in for the
last three they put the little ears you
know bouncing around one of the things
about I was interesting about this is
that animation has kind of there's
multiple Styles but there's like fluid
perfectly everything moving and fluid
and all that sort of stuff but on a
character like Yoda I find it a little
strange I must admit it's too fluid yeah
they like having Yoda do all those flips
and stuff it was creating like these
really intense gimbal lock issues for
the animation they had to create this
whole new rig for him to be able to
actually do that yeah and that shot
there where Dooku jumps up completely CG
really so the beginning of the shot the
big reveal of Yoda whipping out his
lightsaber you know we're also
distracted by the cool lightsaber
moments but there's so much going on on
top of that primarily the marrying of
animation and simulation specifically
with his robe you know that you start it
out animating Yoda where he like reaches
over he pulls back the his robe to get
the lightsaber but then you have to
actually simulate the robe on top of
that and that's going to be a direct
response to that animation but it's not
going to be perfect so then you get the
simulation back and you're like oh but
now the animation isn't quite
translating as much so then you have to
then reanimate his movement to match the
simulation that was done on that
animation and then you do it again by
re-simming the cloth and then you go
back and fix the animation again and
it's kind of like this back and forth
iteration until you kind of get these
things working because especially 20
years ago there weren't really systems
in place to really just hit a button and
be like all right I animated this thing
and now the cloth will just work and so
yeah shout out to Juan Luis and Tim
Harrington for doing these shots here
and that was just something I never saw
in any behind the scenes they're talking
about it online I thought it was really
cool that type of principle still
applies today despite the better tools
you know it's like going back and forth
yeah until it gets a little bit better a
little bit better until you get to like
right at the end yeah basically what you
want to over annunciate so basically
what happens is they would have done the
reveal and then they would have handed
that over to the cloth guys and then
they would have done the cloth but then
it would have hidden the animation so
maybe what you would have done is pushed
your shoulder forward a little bit more
revealed a little bit more given a pause
because the animator wouldn't have been
working with the cloth the irony is is
we are constantly sticking parts of
costumes to the actor so that it stops
obscuring them hair is a big one like
you'll end up have asking the actor to
do something and they'll move and the
hair will just go like that and you're
like okay we can't see your performance
so we end up holding hair back in
certain areas so that when they do that
particular movement so it's the same
principle except it's a digital version
of it like if this was a real little
green Jedi on set and he had a real robe
they would have gone we can't see your
hand do you mind we're just going to
tape that up there they would have
totally have taped it there and they
would have gone you know what they would
have done seven different takes of him
doing the reveal they would have gone
hold it a little longer give us more
purpose more purpose in that you know so
it's exactly basically doing a digital
version of it except you're now making
what on visual effects where you can do
anything but really what you need to do
is base it on real life and what the
decisions you make for the storytelling
point of view I saw another example and
love death and robots the episode called
the witness which I'm a massive fan of
the style of it is incredible but the
costume work in that I think is using
some pretty amazing new tech that you
can actually get off the shelf wait wait
wait hold up hold up are you saying
we're about to take a look at love death
and robots one of our most requested
things ever yeah I'm a huge fan I mean
I'm a huge fan as well I love both
seasons and season three's coming out
soon and this was a particularly awesome
episode in the first season
foreign
it's beautiful to look at yeah it's got
a very cool aesthetic absolutely I'm a
huge fan of this and Arcane is like the
the just the color work and the layout
work and amazing animation just amazing
animation I guess it's motion capture
slash maybe it's hand animated probably
a mix of both I think it's a mix and
it's all stylized and yet it weirdly has
this photorealistic feel to it like look
at that crumpled jacket that she's got
when she gets in and then puts a cloth
bag over the top of it which then folds
down on the the weight of the other one
yeah these days there's a program called
Marvelous Designer that's mostly used
for like designing clothing for
characters in a digital environment and
I guess it also does very good cloths
simulations as well you can't just have
a cloth stick to a body perfectly it's
going to crinkle in certain ways it's
going to move with its own momentum in
certain ways yeah it's interesting
actually you know when you work in real
superhero films and so on they end up
trying to remove the imperfections and
you know this sort of we might be on a
point now where we're going a little bit
more and leave giving some of those
imperfections in there everybody had
this vision of the Spider-Man suit and
the Spider-Man suit looked a particular
way with the comics and Men you can't do
that in real life you felt like you're
compromising so they would go in and fix
it or potentially do digital body work
in this one what's lying underneath is
that girl moving around she's wearing
like this skin tight clothing but it's
all creasing right where it needs to go
and you're just naturally leaving that
happen the render engine is very
photorealistic but all of the texture
work is stylized and that combination is
creating this really cool aesthetic
every frame is like this and Arcane did
the same thing every frame is just a
beautiful single frame you might want to
probably not show that probably well
okay I guess that was on the website
not on YouTube subscribe for that all of
these shows are are really trying to
push the edge of like what's
aesthetically possible in a movie
because you know for the longest time it
was either what you could film or what
you could draw and then eventually what
you could render but they all kind of
existed in these separate categories and
so I think it really started with enter
the spiderverse of starting to kind of
merge those sort of categories together
anyway have fun whoever edits this
sorry hey I know you got some comments
in mind that you want to type down in
the comment section below so you might
as well just do that right now about
what I don't know just got comments
right good things how's the video going
so far on a scale from one to ten
how good is this video leave a comment
down below anybody that wants to hear
more Australian accent comment down
below I'll be back thank you so much for
hitting that subscribe button dangling
that Bell
but also check out the Punisher Channel
Clint's personal YouTube channel if you
want to learn more about how to do
visual effects how to break into the
industry Clint's got tons of tutorials
and videos to kind of just show you
everything you need to know thanks Ryan
dude you almost had a million
subscribers now I think it's gonna
happen this year and I finally got my
email switched over so it's not the
email that doesn't exist anymore hope
we'll see we'll see so you better help
out it by making him hit a million come
learn some VFX with me
so Joe is there anything that you would
like our viewers to see since last time
um you guys uh really gave us some love
when it came to a little short film I
made with my son and we thought we'd
probably come up with a sequel he
doesn't fit into the car anymore so
that's no longer an option but we were
thinking he's really into a foil board
and we built one at home and we want to
convert it to electric and we'll show
you a foil boarding koalakana 2 which we
hope to uh people will enjoy as much as
they did the last one Joe dude it was it
was a treat to be on the couch with you
again man thank you so much for coming
down and doing this I love hanging out
with you guys this is this is fun